they're afternoon it's always a pleasure
to be here I said I heard that one gets
an extra five minutes for every mention
of the chairs name in the talk so I
decided so aim so the main so in the
previous hour you heard about the five
or six different papers by a yell and
now you'll hear about two more so so a
one is a giant just with the AL on a
random box and Rome luton graphs and I
will contrast it with work joint with al
Allen sly and Nathaniel Bernstein ski on
for random walks on random graphs and
and and okay so let's
okay so so we'll compare a the main
emphasis will be on sander graphs so the
best expanders will be Roman Newton
graph self emphasized then there are
random regular graphs which are almost
as expanding as as these ramanujam
graphs and we'll also compared with the
most classical random graph model the
erdos-renyi random graph and see how the
random walks behave in all settings this
one will be connect to the previous talk
because there we will see the effect of
the initial state on mixing now recall
these definitions you just saw in the
last hour the mixing time is the first
time where the distance to total
variation in total variation of the
distribution at time T to the station
distribution is most epsilon here the
our station solutions will be very
simple there'll be uniform distributions
if we have a regular graph and in
general just proportional to the degrees
and a the dependence on epsilon is
captured by the cutoff phenomenon so in
general mixing time the stomach's of
epsilon will
and it could depend on epsilon and to
understand it we look at this is a graph
of the distance this this distance the
distance in total variation to the
stationary distribution so this graph
always decays exponentially once it goes
below a half but some cases it decays
faster and this is the case of cut off
so we captured by looking at this team
except salon where you reach epsilon and
this besides depending on epsilon
there's also an implicit dependence on
the size of the system and what we'd
like is that the ratio of team except
salon and team except salon prime will
go to one as the system goes to the size
of the system goes to infinity so that
will be the cutoff phenomenon and the
simplest examples of car or shouldn't
say the simplicity earliest examples of
cutoff were in the setting of groups so
random turns positions on the
permutation groups you have n cards
choose one card with the left hand one
card with the right hand and transpose
them it might be the same card and so
there's an easy lower bound their of n
log n over 2 because you have to
essentially touch all cards before you
can mix because the random permutation
just has one fixed point in expectation
but the non trivial thing is that n log
n over 2 is really gives you the a
mixing time so up to four you know and
so that's the mixing time with the right
constant so n log n over 2 with the
higher order correction random walk on
the hypercube is another example in some
case simpler so we take the lazy around
the walk we have n bits choose a bit at
random and replace it by a fresh random
bit that's the lazy random walk on the
hypercube and again the mixing time
turns out to be n log n over 2
this time you actually don't have to
touch all coordinates of the hypercube
if you touch all but root n that's
enough to mix these are the simplest
example or the classical examples of of
cut off and it's instructive than in
both of these and in all the classical
examples of cut off the as the system
grows to infinity also the degree goes
to infinity and this is connected to the
scheme of proof so in the classical
examples of cut off the lower bound of
mixing was obtained by finding a
specific event that had that exhibited
the lower bound so that this event a had
very different probabilities under the
distribution at time T and the station
distribution and that kind of give us a
lower bound for the mixing time the
upper bound was obtained by using Cauchy
Schwarz you bounded l1 by l2 so the l1
distance is sent twice its total
variation bundle 1 by l2 and then in
examples where you understand the
spectrum you can compute the l2 norm of
the density so that was the general
scheme as we see this scheme is very
problematic in the case of bounded
degree graphs so particular I'll explain
why in Ramanujan graphs such a scheme
cannot work because the mixing time in
l2 really happens at a different time a
different constant multiple then the
mixing time in l1 so the phenomenon of
backtracking slows down the mixing in l2
more than it does in l1 and that means
that you really do need a different idea
to prove mixing in l1 in bounded degree
graphs or this will
welcome so these are the two example
this is the canonical example of cut off
you have a hypercube half n log n is the
mixing time with a lower order
correction here is the canonical example
of non cut off namely a psycho the
mixing time and the cycle is order N
squared but the constant depends on the
epsilon that you want so Kim mix of
epsilon is behaves like N squared
multiplied by a log of 1 over epsilon so
when if you change epsilon you really
change the constant that multiplies the
N squared and so these are and
contrasting behaviors and intuitively
cutoff is happening in a high
dimensional situation we're mixing
involves a lot of different weakly
dependent variables that should or
somehow reach their stationarity while a
in the cases of low dimension where we
really have one variable then we don't
expect cut off now this is a rough
picture and you know making it rigorous
is one challenge against posed by
Alderson deccan is some 30 years ago now
we're going to focus from this general
setup to case of random walks and
expanders so a regular expander is a
sequence of the regular graphs it can be
defined where this spectral gap is
bounded below or the relaxation time
which is just 1 over the spectrograph is
bounded above and it also has of course
a we finish a more computer definition
in terms of expansion but this one will
be the more important for us now
it's well known in classical that for
such graphs the mixing time so T mix of
epsilon for any epsilon if n is large
enough it can be bounded above and below
by constant multiples of log n so the
dependence on epsilon is bounded but the
question is you know are the cnc prime
the same and well not always so here is
what we'll come to that now we want to
understand random walk and expanders one
class of expanders which is better
understood that the random regular
graphs and and there there was an early
result by a very best its key and direct
that says that on gnd I'm focusing on D
equals 3 just for clarity but everything
here works for higher degree as well so
on gn3 the way the distance from the
starting point behaves is very simple it
increases a trait one-third until you
reach distance log2 n which is the
diameter and then it stays fixed so this
is V a graph of the expected distance
notice the distance itself fluctuates
but the expected distance the first
order has this very simple behavior now
where does the one-third come from
that's very very simple to understand
because a if you have a three regular
graph it is locally like a three regular
looks like a three regular tree and on a
three regular tree you have a drift of
one-third this probability two-thirds
you move further from the starting point
one-third you move closer so that speed
one-third is what leads to the factor a
of one-third in this formula and to the
three in this graph in for general d
one-third is going to be replaced by d
minus two over d because in a general v
regular true you have drift of
probability d minus 1 over d of going
further and 1 over d of
going closer to the starting point so
based on this picture a direct
conjecture that the mixing time is a
asymptotic to three log base 2 n with
high probability and indeed this result
gives you a lower bound it cannot mix or
it's it's actually very easy to get a
lower bound of this nature so the
non-trivial aspect is the upper bound
this was proved by lubetkin slagging
2010 that a the simple random walk
indeed has cut off at this time so d / d
minus 2 is a speed term and this
multiplies log of n to base d minus 1
and this was based on a reduction of
simple random walk to non burger king
wok and then a very precise result for
the non burger king wok so if you have
Joey so what is the window I didn't I
didn't spell that out so so with so if
we look at tea mix of epsilon and so
take epsilon which is less than half and
look at team except cell compared to tea
mix of 1 minus epsilon so when epsilon
is small smaller this is going to be
bigger and aim the wing so we say the WN
is a window for the mixing if we have
such an inequality holding so remember
this tea mixer let me put an end here so
we have a system of size n we want this
to be bounded by C epsilon times some
window size and to have cut off this
window should be negligible compared to
the mixing time itself
ok so the cutoff just means that this
difference is little over the mixing
time but sometimes we can get a bound a
concrete bound which is better than that
and that is called the window well an
upper bound for the window but here
really the best window you can obtain
this root login so it's it's not true so
this kind of inequality is true with WN
which is root log n but it fails if WN
is little oh that's the window and it
reflects in this picture if we look at
the total variation to stationarity so
it decays like that and the window tells
you a this is the size of the window
where you go from a from total variation
distance 1 minus epsilon to total
variation distance epsilon within this
window of course the width of the window
is influenced by epsilon but only in
this multiplicative constant ok so
the way simple random walk is related to
the non backtracking random walk is just
by this factor of D over D minus 2
namely if you can get a bound for the
non burger king wok of the mixing time
then you can just multiply that by this
factor and get a bound for the simple
random walk in l1 this doesn't work in
l2 but it works in l1 and the reason is
is very simple you can just lift to the
tree and if you look on the Trianon
burger king wok is just walking forward
on the tree so if I'm walking for L
steps on the tree on a non battering
walk I just reach to a uniform vertex at
distance L but if I do a simple random
walk for 40 steps then I will still
which I will reach a random level of the
tree but this random level is going to
be very concentrated near d minus 2 over
D times the time so if I if I run for
time T simple random walk this will be
like a like running l which is d minus 2
over d times t steps of the non
backtracking random walk with the lower
order correction which doesn't matter
here because what you'll get is some
mixture of levels of the tree and then
and all these levels will be close to
this level with an error of order
routine so this kind of so maybe I'll
write this plus an error of order root T
and this root T will lead to this window
of root log n here because the tea that
we will need to run will be order log in
so putting these together gives this
result for the random de regular graph
on the other hand
okay I'll skip this and just say that so
this answer is for random the regular
graph it turns out that you don't have
mixing you not have cut off for all
expand all the regular expanders so
characterizing which deregulate
expanders have cut off is still a
challenge let me switch to now to focus
on the Ramanujan graph
and so I'd already told you what sad
irregular expander and an important
starting point here is the alone bopanna
theorem that says it for if we are now
looking not at the eigenvalues of the
Walkabout the eigenvalues of the
adjacency matrix so this is the
different scaling we don't / d so now
we're looking at the adjacency matrix of
the graph the largest eigenvalue is d
and we're looking at the second
eigenvalue of this adjacency matrix and
so the long bopanna theorem says that
the second eigenvalue is always at least
two Rudy managed to do d minus one minus
an error that goes to zero the same
significance of this number can be stood
in several ways in particular it is the
spectral radius for the infinite
adjacency matrix corresponding to the
infinity regular tree so with this in
mind lebowski philip sonic defined the
Ramanujan graph to be a connected
deregulate where all the eigenvalues
except plus minus d have magnitude that
most to the minus 1 so we're allowing in
or they are allowing an eigen value of
minus D which corresponds to the Viper
tight case as well as d which is always
there but no other eigenvalues outside
this interval and the motivation for
this definition was well that they could
produce such examples so the Boston
Phillips are neck and separately
Margolis an 88 constructed such d
regular graphs if d minus 1 is prime and
there is quite recently an existing
proofs of such graphs by marco
Spillman's reverse tava for a for all d
these at least three to have some
interesting object so here is the lube
otsuki Philip sonic six regular
ramanujam graph or some attempt to view
it when n is so this is a graph on
12,000 vertices and so you see that
locally around the node it behaves like
a tree up to some point but of course
it's a finite graph so eventually it
stops being a tree and our goal is to
understand the structure over here
here's another attempt to view you know
some of this graph these are the
spectral measures of two Ramanujan
graphs one is the graph you just saw and
that is in the foreground here so this
gives you the different eigenvalues with
the multiplicities and in the background
you see another graph which is a random
lift of the peterson graph it's also a
Ramanujam graph in this case although
it's open so so when you take a three
regular peter the standard Peterson
graph you do a thousand lift of that and
they some people here know what a random
lifts otherwise it's just an it's not
crucial for me right now and that's
another a rum rum illusion graph and the
point is to show that the spectral
measures of these graphs could vary
quite quite a bit so it's is it's
conjectured that the end left office of
a three regular graph is Roman Yujin
with positive probability but this is in
the picture you see this particular
sample of this thousand lift which is
Ramanujan but there is no yes it's it's
open to show that this recipe gives you
Ramanujan graphs okay so there are some
motivations for looking at expanders so
this was at least Ramanujan graph
specifically and these
were intensively investigated in the 80s
and early 90s but recently there's been
renewed interest because of some
connections with quantum computing and a
new insights and questions about
distances in these graphs I can't go
into these but you can find on Peters
our next webpage more information about
that particular his student sardari has
shown an infinite family of regular in
revolution graphs with diameter at least
four thirds times log P n I'll come back
to how this fits into the general
picture so again we're going to talk
about mixing timelessness again for the
third time recalling these definitions
of cut off now for simple random walk on
d regular graphs there was a conjecture
of no galan that says almost every
random d regular graphs should be at
least weekly ramanujam which means that
lambda 2 should be too routine minus 1
plus a lower order Corrections and this
was proved by friedman in 2008
one conjecture actually made the in 2004
is that all transitive expander
sequences should have cut off at the
time we didn't have of course a
counterexample to that or I will make
the conjecture but we also didn't have
any example so now at least we have an
example we can show this holds for any
family of transitive expanders which is
ramanuja however al and Alan did
construct examples of expanders these
are not transitive that don't have cut
off so just being an expander sequence
is not enough so here this relates to
what I mentioned earlier it's the
distance of simple random walk from
equilibrium so here you see it on the
lahbati phillips on a graph and this is
distance in l1 in this sense so this
instance l1 is in blue and this is in l2
capped by one so me move on is in the in
red and the point to take away from
these pictures is both of these seem to
have cut off and indeed asymptotically
we know there is cut off but the cut
offs happen at different times so the
ratio between these is not going to 1
and indeed we can prove this rigorously
that cut off happens in both models in
l2 it actually follows from an old
result of Lauren so of course that you
must have cut off but we know exactly
where it happens and it happens at the
strictly later time so this means that
you cannot use directly l2 techniques to
prove cut off on the 44 l1 which we care
about on the revolution grass
however so aim if you look at non
backtracking walk so this is just the
walk where you take a step and then the
next step is uniform among all edges
except the edge that you just walked on
so if you use non backtracking walk then
you see from this empirical picture that
the meeting in l1 and l2 for this for
the number truth walk happen actually
quite close x and indeed asymptotically
I don't have a graph here because
asymptotically as n tends to infinity
non backtracking walk in l1 and l2 both
you know just mixes that at this number
log with demands one of n two first
order so the constant here is one is the
point I'm emphasizing this is for non
backtracking walk this is what we want
to capitalize on and here is the let me
state the main theorem for the Ramanujan
case so in any sequence of D regular
graphs which is Ramanujam here I want to
make them non bipartite but the tiny
correction deals with a bipartite cases
well so if they're non bipartite then
you have cut off so the mixing time team
except salon is D over D minus two x log
demands when n with a lower order
correction for all epsilon so this is
exactly what gives you cut off now in
the Viper tight case of course the
random walk formally does never mix it
but you can fix that by making one lazy
step so this is a is this jonathan here
this is connected to a general
phenomenon conjectured by aldo sand and
that worked out with Jonathan but I
can't that but in this case we can just
see it directly so that's Justin Herman
so there's some general phenomenon but
in this case it's very concrete we can
take one lazy step so with probability
half move with probability half stay in
place
end and then the rest just runs around
the walk and then the result still holds
in the in the back protect case exactly
the same way you just have to add a
single lazy step any question about the
statement it one thing I'm to mention
this theorem holds the way I stated it
also for weekly Ramanujan graph you
don't need lambda to be strictly less
than or than to Rudy minus one and error
little o of 1 is fine and particularly
this reproduces in a much harder way the
older result of Alan and Al on mixing of
random the regular graph but of course
it holds for other graphs beyond the
random de regular case in particular for
random lifts and one can also allow to
have a few exceptions so if the number
of exceptions is sub polynomial namely
eigen values that are outside the
Ramanujan interval then it's still fine
and you get the same result
one geometric or allure of the results
when is that is something about
distances in Ramanujan graphs so we
still don't know what is the diameter or
what are the possible diameters of
Ramanujan graphs they certainly at least
log n two base d minus 1 because that's
true for any D regular graph and a
without going back to the 80's improved
by fine changan and others is that twice
log demons when n is an upper bounds the
diameters between log n two base de
venise one and twice that but whether
the factor two can be attained we don't
know and that's that's an open question
one thing we can say is that for most
vertices the true answer is log to base
d minus 1 n so if you don't so the
diameter of course concerns the the
worst case the farthest / vs. but is but
if I fix X and I ask a four vertices why
almost all of them will be a distance
log D minus one in so those that violate
that by even a tiny epsilon will be a
little o of n proportion however there
could be this little event proportion
which increase which even double the
this log demands when it so this result
easily allows you to recover the fact
that the diameter is at most twice
logged immense women because if you have
any two arbitrary vertices X and Z you
could just use triangle inequality with
a random vertex in the middle and you'll
get the upper bound of two so it
reproduces the known upper bound on the
amateur but it tells that for most
vertices the answer is log demands one
end and this result which we obtained
from the non burgeoning walk was proved
independently and using a different
approach by sardari a
use chebyshev polynomials with non
Burger King walks which is our approach
we can get some more information because
we don't get just distance between
vertices with the a distance between
directed edges if you have fixit the one
directed edge then for almost every
other directed edge you can find a path
from the first to the second a directed
path of the requisite length log D minus
1 in and having a directed path from one
edge to another is stronger than just
going from a vertex to vertex because
it's very hard in these graphs to turn
around because they tend to have high
growth okay we also a can demonstrate
with cut off an LP distance due to the
time I'm going to notice discuss that at
length but we can understand exactly how
the mixing time depends on p when you
look at the LP distance and the key
takeaway is that it really varies with
the different p so every p that you are
looking at is you a different mix of
time and this is quite different than
the picture say in the hypercube the
other thing we know is it for air for
all p the Ramanujan graphs really are
the fastest possible mixing of any D
regular graph in LP so for any P you'll
get a different optimal mixing time in
the Ramanujan crafts will saturate that
optimum simultaneously for RP so the key
tool as I've been relating is this non
backtracking random walks so that you
move from X to an edge this is a edge
value chain you move from an edge XY to
an edge YZ so that Z naught equal x this
has been used as a it's quite a popular
tool it was used in Friedman's work and
co-authors it was used by sharper than
avenue refinement of of this classic
work and in the earlier work of Aylan
island i mentioned and it's also now
being used
out in community detection problems that
many people here have worked on and in
our proof on the Ramanujan graphs we use
non veg certain works and also some new
property of them that I want to
highlight so it a be an adjacency matrix
of the graph itself G and these lambda 1
lambda 2 and so on are the eigenvalues
the adjacency matrix we look at the set
of directed edges and then we have this
non backtracking matrix so be of two
edges UV and XY is going to be just one
if V equals x but you must be d be
different from Y so this is exactly the
condition that these edges follow each
other and there is a known connection
between the eigen values of a and of be
known as the bass formula that says for
any eigen value lambda of a solve this
quadratic equation you get two solutions
and these give you a gang values of B
and this give all the interesting again
values of B there are some few other
less interesting ones I mentioned but
these are all the important eigen values
or B solutions of this quadratic
equation so this is known but we can say
more so we can give the exact Jordan the
composition of the non-doctor key matrix
the issue with nice non-virtual King
matrix if we want to understand simple
random walk its classical that we want
to diagonalize the matrix and then take
powers of this matrix we give really
understand the simple random walk the
problem with the non-banking matrix it's
not diagonalizable it's not even normal
so it looks like that approach is doomed
and one thing I mean this bass formula
is is well known and initially we
thought in this in the revolution case
we shouldn't profit from passing to non
barking works because we have an
equivalence between the eigen
values and we know that the spectral
approach direct threat will approach to
compute l2 distance fails on these
graphs of bounded degree we are and then
so how could an equivalent form of the
spectrum in the non-veteran case help
but it turns out that the it does help
really the what the cause of the
difference between and l1 and l2 for
bounded degree graphs is the
backtracking and once you get rid of the
backtracking you get rid of the
difference so it so what is the result
you have eigenvalues so if we look at
this matrix B of course it's much larger
than a because it's it's an edge it's on
the space of edges so capital n is the
number of edges and so we have a lot of
a plus minus 1 eigen values that are
unimportant there is the eigenvalue d
minus 1 which just comes from the fact
that the chain from every edge you have
d minus 1 edges you can go to but then
all the interesting eigenvalues happen
here in pairs so these are the a bass
augen values you see here but what we
can add to this picture from bass is
that the jordan form just has consist of
these small two by two cells and we can
say exactly what is the extra term in
these cells now this would be
straightforward if all the eigen values
of a were distinct because then you have
this for each eigenvalue have this solve
the quadratic equation you get a pair
and you have to have this two-by-two
structure the difficulty is that in many
cases of interest in particular the
lebowski philip sonic case the
eigenvalues come with very high
multiplicity and so it's not obvious
that you don't have get large blocks in
the jordan form but in fact you don't
they're all two by two and we can
identify what is this extra terms are in
the running engine case all these extra
terms have magnitude exactly d minus 2
once you have this explicit structure
you can almost work with this as if it's
a diagonal matrix and just calculate the
behavior of the random walk by taking
powers of this matrix
because we really know how to take a
power of a two by two triangular matrix
let's say something we can manage so so
just following that aim so so the idea
is suppose first the matrix was diagonal
and mutti is the distribution of the non
burger king wok then to find the mu t is
just obtained by taking be to a high
power and normalizing by d minus 1 to
the t because remember B is not normal
and then when you do that you compute
the l2 distance so this would be if it
was diagonal you would just simply
compute this using the eigenvalues these
are the unimportant plus minus 1 eigen
values the T we're going to take is log
the minus 1 n and this immediately
implies this term will be negligible and
so the term of interest is here arising
from these bus eigenvalues and what you
get because we take T to be logged I
minus 1 n what you'll get here will be a
easy to compute the one thing I should
have I skip this slide so one thing
which is known when you solve this
quadratic equation in the Ramanujan case
all the these Thetas all the bus
eigenvalues you get will lie on the
circle of radius root B minus 1 and of
course they come in conjugate pairs so
the main point these are all of
magnitude Rudy minus 1 so this will be
rudi minus 1 to the power 2 log n so
this will this will give you and Rudy
oops so
so so this and you have you have n terms
here so what you get is that this will
cancel one factor of the of the D minus
1 to the T and what you're left with is
well essentially n from the number of
summands / d minus 1 to the T and by
just pushing T a little bigger than log
D minus 1 n you will make this smaller
than Epsilon this would be the picture
of the matrix is diagonal it's not
diagonal but it's close enough that the
same argument works with a small
correction and instead of a constant
here we need to go a log log n but then
the argument goes through so the last
thing I want to say about this before
briefly returning to the random graphs
is to mention one tool that we use so
this is a tool from from this book with
Ross Lyon's probability and trees and
networks which was finally a couple of
months ago submitted to the publisher
after 19 years but it's still available
we'll stay freely available on the web
anyway so this is the tool if you have
be as an electrical matrix B inverse is
its inverse it's B it's invertible if
you take B inverse and add D minus 1
times being us to be then miraculously
the matrix you get is now a matrix on
the edge set it's symmetric and you can
write out explicitly what it is and
check that it's symmetric the point is
that this of course we started with the
matrix a which is itself symmetric they
just see the matrix of the original
graph but that's a smaller space see is
a matrix on the same space the edge
space as be and it's symmetric so we
know it is diagonalizable but when you
have this form it's easy to go back and
forth between again values of B and
eigen values of C because if you have
any eigen value of B then you take that
I ghen value and add D minus 1 times its
inverse you'll get an eigen value of C
but because C asymmetric it is
diagonalizable and this is one
explanation of the simple structure of
the extraordinary
questions about this
so now I want to just quickly turn to
tell you what are the substantial
differences in the in the random case
so so in the order shrunk Randy random
graph model you have the different
phases and we'll be focusing on the
super critical phase and random walk on
the giant cluster I have to give this
picture aim the random walk on the
critical inside the clinical window is
very interesting but now we're going to
focus on the super critical case where
so p is larger than 1 over N so 1 plus
epsilon over n say but here epsilon is
fixed not going to 0 and then the size
of the component is some constant times
n the mixing time is log squared of N
and this was discovered by read from two
lackeys and independently slightly later
by being a meany kozma or melt and why
is this mixing time log squared of n
easy to understand the lower bound
because the structure of the giant
component is that it has these long
paths that connect to the main body of
length log in if you start at the end of
this long path it will take you time at
least logs for them to reach the main
body so that gives you a lower bound for
the mixing time and then the non trivial
thing is to show that after you reach
the main body it's still only logs were
the end so you also have an upper bound
let me say that even if you look at the
two core so you remove all the leaves
and keep removing the leaves you still
get log squared n because there are long
paths here that are in the two core and
if you start in the middle of such a
path you will still have log square then
so the mixing time is all the locks
within and there's no cutoff because
it's dominated the mixing time is
dominated by random walk on the path and
there's no cut off their it could take
an arbitrarily long large constant times
log square then so what we find in this
case is you get a more interesting
behavior when you start from a typical
vertex as opposed to from this worst
case and I'll just maybe jump to to what
is the result and the result is that the
mixing time here is order log n and
there is cut off when you start at the
uniform vertex so this is quenched so
you choose a vertex uniformly at random
and then you fix that vertex and look at
the mixing time from that vertex and
it's log n times some known constants
from the behavior of random Oakland got
knots and trees and I can't go into much
detail on these constants but I say that
this constant here V represents the
speed of random walk on the government's
entry so just like in this case the
speed of random walk on the regular tree
play the role here in the random graph
the local structure is not of a a
regular tree but of a branching process
cut Watson tree and the speed of random
walk on that comes in but we also have
another factor which is if you have
around a regular tree then obviously
random walk will spread uniformly on
every level when it hits that level this
is no longer true young guns most no
longer true and Gavin Watson trees
namely there you have some non
uniformity of the hitting distribution
if you look at the level of K and wait
till the random walk hits level K it
doesn't hit it uniformly it hits it a at
a highly highly non uniform way and in
fact if the size of the taste level is
some mean to the K there will be a
strictly smaller set of size say you
know min minus Delta to the K which
supports the random walk and this is the
dimension of harmonic measure which
comes in in these mixing estimates so
aim so i have to skip many details and
just end with a couple of open problems
so one which is open but we've recently
made progress again with Al and also
angaben hmoo is the case of comparing
non backtracking walk to simple random
walk so here I should I should really
mentioned something about non
backtracking walk in this random setting
so we talked about it in the Randall in
the wrong illusion case but one can also
look at Nonnberg circling walk in the
random case it's easier to analyze in
the random case then the simple random
walk and it basically can be analyzed by
an adaptation of the proof from the
regular graphs case
so the non Burger King random walk you
also have a cut off and this part for
number 13 walk was in our paper but also
independently in work of an urban camo
and Justine salads who is here somewhere
Justine there Thanks and he will talk
about related work later what and right
and they a they have more information on
the window in this case so looking at
these two things prompt the question
does non burger king wok mix faster in
the random graph with given degree
sequence a then simple random walk so
here I don't want to look at air the
show any graph because that has leaves
so let's take a random graph as a random
degree sequence with no leaves so all
degrees are at least two so the non
burger king wok is is well defined is it
true that the number 13 walk mix is
faster so that we still don't know but
what we recently with an urban harmoo
and they are verified that it's true if
all degrees are bigger strictly bigger
than two so yes condition that the
degreaser at least three so i have it's
not so i fix the degree sequence all the
degrees are is threaten our theorem all
the degrees are at least three and now
pick a uniform graph among or grass with
this degree sequence and compare the
mixing time of the simple and walk in
the numbers with nemo now of course
backtracking is wasteful so it's natural
to expect that the non-working walk will
mix faster the difficulty is that this
waste for in the random case this waste
also leads to the simple random walk is
also more selective on where it goes so
it doesn't enter very thin parts of the
graph it tends to backtrack more out of
them so we have a tension between two
factors on the one hand canceling the
backtracking speeds you up on the other
hand
canceling the backtracking also makes
the walk less selective and you have to
see how the tension between these two
factors that create some complications
but we can handle them of degrees are
bigger than two and finally returning
more to the regular case one thing that
is still open is this original
conjecture that's lazy simple random
walk have cut off and every family of
transitivity regular expanders we now
know it for in the revolution case but i
still believe it's true in greater
generality thanks for your attention